good afternoon i'm sorry to have to tell
you
that today the number of deaths recorded
from covid
in the uk has surpassed a hundred
thousand
and it's hard to compute the sorrow
contained in that grim
statistic the years of life
lost the family gathering is not
attended and for so many relatives
the missed chance even to say goodbye
i offer my deepest condolences to
everyone
who's lost a loved one fathers and
mothers brothers
and sisters sons and daughters and the
many grandparents
who've been taken and to all those who
grieve we make this pledge
that when we've come through this crisis
we will
come together as a nation to remember
everyone
we lost and to honor
the selfless heroism of all those on the
front line
who gave their lives to save others
we will remember the courage of
countless working people not just our
amazing nhs and
care workers but shop workers transport
staff
pharmacists teachers police
armed forces emergency services
and many others who kept our country
going during our biggest crisis
since the second world war we will
commemorate the small acts of kindness
the
spirit of volunteering and the daily
sacrifice of millions
who placed their lives on hold time and
again
as we fought each new wave of the virus
buying time for our brilliant scientists
to come
to our aid in that moment of
commemoration we will celebrate the
genius and perseverance of those who
discovered
the vaccines and the immense national
effort
never seen before in our history which
is now underway
to distribute them one that has now seen
us immunize
over 6.8 million people across
the united kingdom and when those
vaccines have finally freed us from this
virus
and put us on a path to recovery
we will make sure we learn the lessons
and reflect and prepare
and until that time the best and most
important thing
we can all do to honor the memory of
those who have died
is to work together with ever greater
resolve
to defeat this disease and that is what
we will do i'm not going to hand over to
chris for the
slides thank you prime minister uh on
this very sad day i've just got three
uh slides the first
is the number of people testing positive
for covid
in the uk and as you can see on this
graph
the number peaked at an extremely high
number
it is still at a very high number but it
has been coming down
i want to just put one caution on that
which is that office for national
statistics data demonstrates a rather
slower decrease
and i think we need to be careful that
we do not relax too early
next slide please the number of people
in hospital with kovid is still
an incredibly high number over 35
000 people and as you can see in this
graph it is flattened off it is not
still rising
overall it is substantially above the
peak in april
and uh over this time it looks as if
it's coming down very slightly in some
areas
including london and the south east and
the east of england
but there are some areas of the country
where that where it is still not
convincingly reducing so it's still at a
very high level
throughout the country and nhs staff are
working
incredibly hard with many very sick
coveted
patients next slide please
and finally on this day uh the number of
deaths
uh at the moment this looks as if this
is flattened out but at a
very high level so the most recent
seven-day average for deaths the rolling
seven-day average
uh is uh 1242 deaths
uh an incredibly high number and i think
we have to be realistic that
the rate of mortality the number of
people dying a day
will come down relatively slowly over
the next
uh two weeks and will probably be flat
for a while
uh now so we will still unfortunately be
having
additional deaths to add to that very
sad
total that the prime minister talked
about thank you very much
thank you very much chris so have
anything you want to add
i think really just to thank my fellow
staff across the health service
for everything that you have done over
the course of the last
year this sunday it'll be a year since
the
first two patients with coronavirus were
treated in hospital
in newcastle and it'll be a year since
the
first flight returned from wuhan to
arrow park hospital
for quarantining of people returning to
this country
and it's a year in which over a quarter
of a million
severely ill coronavirus patients have
been looked after
in hospital and those staff who have
been looking after those patients
also of course experience what this
pandemic has meant
as daughters and as sons and as parents
and as grandchildren with family
and friends and neighbors and so this is
not a year that anybody is going to want
to remember
but nor is it a year that across the
health service any of us will ever
forget